JEROME SILBERGELD: Trying to study
architecture from a photograph
or a slide is a
little bit like trying
to understand a movie
by reading about it.
You really have
to see the thing.
You really have to be there.
You have to experience it.
HENRIQUE DE FREITAS: It became completely
an intellectual experience.
Every rock, every shape of
the pond and every plant
asks a question
from you and you're
trying to find the answer.
And there's just not enough
time to answer all of them,
but that's what I
enjoyed most about being
able to actually walk through
these gardens as opposed
to just talking about them
or looking at pictures.
PHWAY AYE: I sort of thought
that going into the gardens,
it would be a professor
led discussion.
But there was a lot of fluidity.
I remember Professor Hare
and Professor Silbergeld
always being around to
facilitate discussions.
But at the same time,
we had a lot of leeway
to walk around individually
and experience it ourselves.
So any time I found
myself walking
around a certain feature
and if I had a question
or if I had something
I was curious about,
a professor would always be
around to spark that or just
continue that
conversation with me.
THOMAS HARE: We told them to
find a feature in the gardens
that we toured and to
focus on that feature
throughout the week
and then tell us
something about the feature
in their second paper, once we
got back.
We didn't tell them
what a feature was.
We didn't identify any
specific kinds of things.
But they came up with lots
of different possibilities,
including things as broad as
just the idea of space itself.
A couple of students worked
on sound in the gardens,
and we had students work
on paths, and sand-- trees.
HENRIQUE DE FREITAS: It opened
a completely new world
in the academic field of
history of art, of culture,
of religion-- things
that I hadn't really
considered much before
and that now I just
can't wait to go into.
JEROME SILBERGELD: I have never
worked, in all of my time
here, with a more enthusiastic
group of students,
especially after
the trip, or a group
of students that had more
closely bonded together,
got to really know each other,
work together, share topics,
share information, learn
together, teach each other.
And I think it is fair to
say that the opportunity
to undertake a trip
like this-- and we're
doing more and more
courses like this
so that more and more students
can participate in classes
of this kind-- really gives
them a unique experience.
[MUSIC PLAYING]